[Música]
[Aplausos]
cuando en el año 2014 el por aquel
entonces presidente de los eeuu barack
obama anunció su intención de alcanzar
un acuerdo con el régimen de los
ayatolás sobre el programa nuclear iraní
las relaciones entre riad y washington
comenzaron a resquebrajarse la vieja
alianza la antigua sociedad la relación
especial entre estos dos países que
comenzó allá por 1945 cuando el
presidente de eeuu franklin roosevelt se
reunió con el rey saudí en el canal de
suez empezó de repente a venirse abajo
para arriba del pacto de washington con
terán fue poco menos que una traición y
desde entonces las cosas han ido de mal
en peor ahora la invasión rusa de
ucrania y la negativa sistemática de
rían de apoyar la posición y las
peticiones de los eeuu han puesto las
cosas peor que nunca pero ahora bien por
qué demonios arabia saudita siga
poniendo a rusia incluso aunque eso
pueda poner en riesgo su especial
relación con eeuu porque las relaciones
entre riad y washington se han
deteriorado tanto que queda de la vieja
amistad entre estos dos países podrá
acaso yo bailé en recomponer la relación
queridos amigos amigas en este vídeo
responderemos a todas estas preguntas
pero lo primero lo primero de todo es
saber dónde comenzó esta relación
especial y antes de todo un anuncio pero
que muy interesante
[Música]
os hago una pregunta habéis escuchado
hablar alguna vez de el metaverso si
estoy convencido de que pagos
absolutamente todos habéis escuchado
hablar de ello pero sabéis realmente en
qué consiste en qué implicaciones tiene
es puro humo o realmente estamos a las
puertas de una nueva revolución digital
porque empresas de todo el mundo están
invirtiendo miles de millones de dólares
en esta especie del mundo virtual pues
queridos amigos amigas si queréis
aclarar todas estas dudas no os perdáis
el último vídeo de si lo hubiera sabido
el canal de información financiera de
mutuactivos con el que participamos con
un canal en el que también podéis
encontrar otros muchísimos vídeos entre
ellos uno que se preguntaba si el
hidrógeno puede llegar a sustituir las
importaciones de gas ruso de la unión
europea os dejamos toda la info en la
descripción pero dicho esto continuemos
la relación especial
[Música]
en 1945 el presidente roosevelt y el rey
saudí saud sellaron el pacto petróleos
tras defensa un pacto por el que eeuu
logró petróleo a precios razonables al
tiempo que como contraprestación
garantizaba la seguridad del reino saudí
o mejor dicho de la casa real saudí sea
como sea fue el comienzo de una larga
amistad que dejaría una profunda huella
en la historia mundial aunque realmente
ese no fue el primer gran contacto entre
estos dos países 12 años antes en 1933
el gobierno saudí se asoció con la
standard oil company del mismísimo
rockefeller y así poco a poco se fueron
forjando estrechos vínculos entre estos
dos estados por ejemplo eeuu estableció
una delegación en yeda en 1942 elevando
la embajada en el 49
por su parte el rey saud instó a los
eeuu a abrir un consulado endara en el
44 para servir a los ciudadanos
estadounidenses empleados por la arabian
americana will company ahora conocida
como arango y eso no es todo tan pronto
como en 1943 ya invitó a los eeuu a
construir un aeródromo en dar a que la
fuerza aérea de este país de eeuu
mantuvo hasta 1962 el entendimiento
entre las dos partes era tal que en el
44 de eeuu extendió el programa de
préstamo y arriendo a arabia saudí para
que este país pudiera comprar un montón
de equipos en el gigantesco supermercado
de las armas de los eeuu y poco después
en 1951 a ambos estados firmaron un
acuerdo de asistencia de defensa mutua
un acuerdo que por ejemplo estableció la
primera misión de entrenamiento militar
de eeuu en el reino saudí así que como
veis las cosas vienen de lejos pero un
momento porque pese a todo riad siempre
siempre mantuvo una política exterior
independiente y a diferencia de otros
países del consejo de cooperación del
golfo siempre ha tenido muchas reservas
a la presencia de tropas norteamericanas
en su territorio
por ejemplo al gobierno saudí le costó
mucho tomar la decisión de aceptar el
despliegue de medio millón de soldados
norteamericanos durante la primera
guerra del golfo y más recientemente
durante la inversión de afganistán tras
el 11-s los saudíes no permitieron que
los norteamericanos utilizaran su
territorio para llevar a cabo
operaciones militares al tiempo que
posteriormente fueron muy críticos con
la invasión de irak que todo ello por no
hablar de los dos embargos petroleros
liderados por arabia saudita en 1967
tras la guerra de los seis días y en
1973 tras la guerra árabe-israelí sobre
todo este segundo embargo petrolero
causó estragos en eeuu
así que tal y como podéis ver pues no
hablamos precisamente de una relación de
amor incondicional para nada la relación
especial entre riad y washington ha sido
una parte clave de la política exterior
norteamericana durante las últimas
décadas pero la relación siempre ha
estado marcada por los desencuentros los
recelos y la desconfianza y de hecho
otros países del golfo pérsico tienen
relaciones mucho más estrechas y mucho
mejores con los eeuu
[Música]
por ejemplo bahrein es la sede de la
quinta flota de estados unidos kuwait
acoge a miles de soldados
norteamericanos en ocho bases militares
y en qatar eeuu alberga desde
1996 la base de aludes una de las bases
aéreas más importantes de la potencia
norteamericana en todo el mundo dicho lo
cual las cosas mejoraron cuando tras
llegó a la casa blanca el ex presidente
apostó claramente por arabia saudi en
detrimento de qatar a la hora de fijar
sus prioridades en oriente medio'
incluso aunque ello terminará suponiendo
la salida de su secretario de estado rex
tillerson y a pesar de que qatar es un
estrechísimo aliado de washington pero
amigos sí pareció surgir un cierto
romance la llegada al poder de joe biden
ha significado todo lo contrario
[Música]
los saudíes consideran a la actual
administración estadounidense como la
heredera de la administración obama que
respalda las primaveras árabes quiso
reducir la presencia norteamericana en
oriente medio inició el acuerdo nuclear
con irán todo lo cual enfureció al
gobierno saudí liderado por aquel
entonces por el fallecido rey abdalá
para colmo bailén a diferencia de trump
ha sido tremendamente crítico con el
régimen saudí tras el macabro atroz y
vil asesinato del periodista llama al
caso vida el actual presidente de eeuu
llegó a calificar a arabia saudita de
ser un país paria
pero mucho ojo queridos amigos amigas
porque todos estos desencuentros y
recelos no son sólo cosas del gobierno
saudíes que veréis mohamed bin salman
está impulsando una gran transformación
en el país árabe os hemos hablado de
ello en un montón de vídeos aquí en
visual político sin embargo no es visto
particularmente con buenos ojos por los
norteamericanos digamos que en
washington consideran que el nuevo líder
saudí es una persona demasiado impulsiva
y en la que difícilmente se puede
confiar fijaos
en washington entienden que este
personaje destruido casi por completo el
equilibrio de poderes de la realeza
saudí y que está reformando el sistema
político saudí para que todo gire en
torno a su persona que decide
involucrarse de forma temeraria en la
guerra de yemen pese a las advertencias
de que sería un enorme error que ordenó
el vil asesinato de caso guíu y que para
colmo ha intentado chantajear a eeuu con
su política petrolera en diferentes
ocasiones
[Música]
y todo ello por no hablar del golpe
silencioso que el actual líder de facto
árabe saudita perpetró en 2017 cuando
derrocó hoy encarceló al príncipe
heredero mohamed bin nayef quien
precisamente tenía unas relaciones muy
pero que muy buenas con los eeuu gracias
a su lucha contra la presencia de al
qaeda en el país demasiado para
washington ahora bien que explica tantos
desencuentros no se suponía que ambos
países tenían una relación especial e
incluso una dependencia mutua en campos
tan importantes como la energía la
seguridad o la defensa pues queridos
amigos amigas lo cierto es que durante
las últimas dos décadas se ha producido
un giro copernicano
[Aplausos]
eeuu ha dejado de necesitar el petróleo
saudí y eso eso ha supuesto todo un
punto de inflexión para que os hagáis
una idea hoy las ventas a eeuu
representan menos del 5 por ciento de
las exportaciones totales de crudo saudí
es un petróleo que hoy por hoy se dirige
fundamentalmente al lejano oriente y
sobre todo a países como china japón
corea del sur o taiwán por ejemplo tan
sólo las exportaciones chinas
representan más del doble de todas las
exportaciones de crudo saudí a los eeuu
y podéis creerme cuando digo que esto
esto lo ha cambiado todo la revolución
del siglo en eeuu hizo que washington
dejará de darle tanta importancia a
oriente medio y así estábamos cuando de
repente para colmo llegó la invasión
rusa de ucrania atentos
[Música]
una cuestión de bolsillo
puede terminar siendo un enorme punto de
inflexión riad se ha negado una y otra y
otra vez a condenar a moscú por la cruel
invasión de ucrania e incluso le ha
manifestado un cierto apoyo como socio
del grupo conocido como pepe plus
mientras la casa blanca lideraba una
campaña para aislar a rusia los líderes
de arabia saudita seguía manifestando
cosas como esto arabia saudi señala su
apoyo al papel de rusia no pec plus a
medida que aumenta la presión sobre las
acciones y eso no es todo aún hay algo
que resulta mucho pero que mucho peor
para los intereses norteamericanos árabe
saudí se ha negado tajantemente a
bombear mucho más petróleo para intentar
mitigar el efecto de las sanciones
contra rusia unas sanciones que han
llevado los precios del petróleo y del
gas a sus máximos en más de una década
claro que todo tiene una explicación
[Música]
amigos amigas arabia sigue siendo el
mayor exportador mundial de crudo y con
el barril de brent a más de 100 dólares
el dinero está entrando de nuevo en las
arcas saudíes a raudales y ojo que esto
es mucho pero que mucho más importante
de lo que puede parecer a simple vista
aquí en visual político ya os hemos
contado cómo este país se enfrenta a un
futuro complicado por un lado su
población es muy joven y está
acostumbrado a un nivel de vida
relativamente alto por otro los ingresos
del gobierno ya no dan para mantener a
una población cada vez más grande en una
economía que fundamentalmente sigue
dependiendo del oro negro porque en
arabia básicamente o trabajas para el
gobierno o para la industria petrolera y
poco más
lo que tal y como os podéis imaginar es
una bomba de relojería por eso el
gobierno de mohamed y salman quieren
cambiar esta situación y lo está
haciendo con planes como misión 2030 el
problema es que para llevar a cabo estos
planes del país necesita dinero mucho
muchísimo dinero y financieramente los
últimos años fueron muy pero que muy
malos para el reino entre los años 2015
y 2020 la caída de los precios del crudo
dijo que el país consumir una parte
sustancial de sus reservas de dinero
hablamos de cientos de miles de millones
un agujero que parecía conducirlos
directamente al abismo financiero pero
ahora eso ha cambiado casi por completo
los nuevos y disparados precios del
petróleo implican que ahora árabe saudí
tiene margen para recomponer sus
reservas y volver a financiar
inversiones en empresas extranjeras y en
grandes proyectos que reduzcan su
dependencia del crudo
ganancias inesperadas de los ingresos
adicionales que obtendremos de los altos
precios del petróleo se invertirán
esencialmente en residencia ya sea
reponiendo reservas pagando la deuda o
invirtiendo en proyectos de
transformación únicos a través de
nuestro fondo de riqueza eso realmente
nos ayuda a acelerar los planes de
diversificación faisal ali ibrahim
ministro de economía y planificación de
arabia saudi incluso el gobierno saudí
se está planteando vender más acciones
de harán con el mercado ahora que esta
empresa se ha disparado en bolsa y que
ha vuelto a convertirse la empresa más
valiosa del mundo tras superar a la
mismísima apple
pero claro la cuestión es que para
lograr todos estos planes riad necesita
que los precios del petróleo sigan al
alza durante una buena temporada por
ejemplo tan sólo durante el 2022 se
espera que este país ingrese por sus
ventas de petróleo más de 280 mil
millones de dólares unos 180 mil
millones más que en los años anteriores
y eso eso amigos es mucho muchísimo
dinero así que digamos que el apoyo a
rusia puede pensar lo suficiente el
mercado como para garantizar que todos
esos ingresos sigan llegando y además
puede que en riad estén pensando que
cuando la producción rusa comienza a
reducirse por las sanciones que ellos
puedan colocar mucho más petróleo sin
que esto va a caer sustancialmente los
precios y esto esto le podría dar al
reino un margen de 3 o 4 años de
ingresos extraordinarios como mínimo y
ojo que podemos estar hablando de más de
500 o 600 mil millones de dólares una
fortuna con la que poder acelerar sus
planes de diversificación económica
claro que mucho cuidado con los planes
milagrosos o lo que en españa conocemos
como los cuentos de la lechera atentos
no vendas la piel antes de cazar al oso
[Música]
puede que eeuu ya no sea un cliente tan
importante y puede que ahora real tenga
otras prioridades pero su relación con
el gigante norteamericano sigue siendo
indispensable para la casa salud por
mucho que le pese a mohamed bin salman
eeuu sigue siendo terriblemente
importante para arabia por ejemplo eeuu
es la sede de las grandes finanzas el
comercio y las grandes multinacionales
de todo el mundo tan solo árabe saudí y
un país que busca desesperadamente
diversificar su economía del petróleo
tiene invertidos más de 800 mil millones
de dólares en eeuu frente por ejemplo a
poco menos de 100 mil millones en china
y si aquí alguno podría pensar
esto en todo caso es una debilidad para
eeuu ya que arabia podría [ __ ] su
dinero e irse con él a otra parte sin
embargo un momento porque eso no resulta
tan sencillo arabia quiere diversificar
su economía del petróleo y para ello
necesita a las grandes multinacionales
norteamericanas además por si fuera poco
la petro monarquía tampoco tiene fácil
encontrar otro destino donde poder
depositar semejantes cantidades de
dinero con total seguridad y liquidez
hay eeuu sigue siendo indispensable
y no solo se trata de una cuestión
económica desde el punto de vista
militar la dependencia es incluso mayor
las fuerzas armadas saudíes dependen
casi completamente de la industria
militar norteamericana para que os
hagáis una idea entre 2015 y 2019 el 73
por ciento de las compras militares
saudíes se hicieron a empresas
norteamericanas tan sólo entre los años
2008 y 2020 los saudíes se gastaron en
armas en eeuu más de 145.000 millones de
dólares
por otra parte la invasión rusa de
ucrania le ha dado a riad una enorme
oportunidad de ganar influencia y
recomponer su vieja relación eeuu ahora
necesita otra vez petróleo y lo necesita
esta vez no tanto para sí mismo como
para calmar un mercado terriblemente
estresado antes de que los altísimos
precios del petróleo empiecen a
fracturar sus alianzas internacionales
contra rusia bueno para eso hoy para las
elecciones de 2024 porque veréis la
evidencia nos dice que cada cambio de 10
dólares por barril en el precio del
petróleo resulta en un cambio de entre
25 y 30 centavos en el precio de un
galón de gasolina y por cada centavo que
aumenta el precio promedio de la
gasolina en los eeuu se pierden más de
1000 millones de dólares al año en gasto
adicional de los consumidores es decir
hablamos de decenas y decenas de miles
de millones que las empresas
norteamericanas pueden perder por el
camino
y podéis crear mis testigos que llegaron
las elecciones con el precio de la
gasolina disparado las empresas
perdiendo negocios por valor de decenas
de miles de millones y la economía
tambaleándose en eeuu es casi una
sentencia la derrota electoral es un
hecho y luego tampoco podemos olvidar
aunque su peso no sea cada vez menos
relevante la agenda política
norteamericana el importantísimo papel
que puede jugar a arabia saudita en
materia de seguridad y estabilidad
regional que es justo lo que eeuu
necesita para salir corriendo de oriente
medio y poder centrarse en su gran
objetivo político militar y económico
asia-pacífico arabia saudí es un socio
crítico para nosotros en el tratamiento
del extremismo la región en el
tratamiento de los desafíos planteados
por irán y también espero continuar el
proceso de construcción de relaciones
entre israel y sus vecinos
anthony blinken secretario de estado de
eeuu
sea como sea amigos un próximo viaje de
bailén a la región nos dejará claro si
la relación puede recomponerse o por
contra está herida de muerte de momento
eso sigue riad ha trasladado las
primeras señales de que podría estar
dispuesta a dar su brazo a torcer arabia
saudí está lista para bombear más
petróleo si la producción rusa se hunde
bajo prohibición pero llegado hasta aquí
turno para ti crees que la relación
entre arabia saudita y eeuu puede
recomponerse de veloz unidos buscar
reforzar su vieja alianza o por contra
deberían empezar a considerar a arabia
saudita con un país no amistoso pues
bien dejándonos por aquí abajo vuestros
comentarios y ahora si este vídeo se ha
resultado interesante no olvidéis darle
a like y suscribiros al político si es
que aún no lo habéis hecho una vez más
muchas muchísimas gracias por estar ahí
un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]